welcome to this video playing immortal
from whoops from Argentina I wanted to
play the Banco and then the sky is
playing 93 that's not nice okay so we
probably get them the French type of
position no he doesn't play you form
okay yeah not show up CFC 50 is a well
time to move or not but ok why not if he
takes with the night f9c fire which
looks like very decent pressure on on 24
how does he keep the pawn I don't really
see it
yeah this even e5 and deform for the
real greedy people but if I he can take
d 5 so this is actually a complete
nonsense okay so i can take the king
crab before but he's got he's got long
castles which is which is a problem
hmm I'm not sure but it doesn't make
much sense otherwise if I don't take it
but it looks like it looks dangerous
Knight takes pawn takes an hour-long
castle yeah he's got the noid and maybe
this wasn't so wasn't such a great idea
we should be five in particular looks
like looks like problem and he threatens
to do to move the night so maybe Bishop
c5 this could be an idea it looks very
shaky this position Bishop b5 I must
play Bishop to d7 i move the king yes
discovered checks with the night and and
wins in something check no I must play
Bishop d7 the only move
yeah this looks like this looks like a
very shaky position takes ever take f6
Bishop takes King takes he's got a big
discovered checks are you to take with
the pawn hmm yeah and what I'm wondering
about is a move like going to see three
if he gets out of this this pin what
what is happening then I don't I don't
really know what to play against the
smooth Bishop takes Queen takes and rook
takes I'm sorry he's got this this nasty
pin who not sure yeah maybe this was as
good as well as possible it looks so
very dangerous as long okay but but
still if I'm play Bishop Jake's b5 yeah
maybe ninety six month a brutal move
like that can be a of course very
effective
hmm i don't really see a move him we
should be 59 take c 60 but maybe I can
just take it only six he's given his
given away some material and if it's
just might be five the screen be six it
should be should be okay yeah just take
it Queen takes Bishop e7 check I've got
I've got to push ups and the rook which
is quite a lot the only thing is the
coordination and this is not too worried
but maybe with some moves if I can if I
can get in like Bishop c6 look f eight
and so on then I'm in very good shape
but not not so easy to to manage he's
got three pawns of course two bishops
under look are much stronger than the
Queen but my my king mate comes first
yeah but I've got all pieces when
positioned around the king so this
should be M should be too bad
my pieces managed to coordinate then
I'll even get some attack going on my
own nice she's taking lots of time him I
think if I were in his shoes I would try
to get the edge pawn make sure that i
only have those two pawns please not
play me some connection problem no well
I'm I'm connected at least and let's
check oh I cannot I cannot ping him at
the moment maybe he's got a connection
issue I don't think he disconnected
willingly yeah that sound lucky it's
such an interesting game it seems that
he lost contact with the cinema maybe is
able to reconnect sometimes at this is
successful this kind of reconnect yeah
that's a shame the position is really
interesting
hmm yeah I don't know is there some
tricky move here to make use of this
hanging bishop yeah it's more of a
theoretical thing now he will lose some
time yeah do tonight forfeits due to
this connection yeah it's a shame such
an interesting game you know the
computer is very optimistic but I'm not
sure about that queen for a queen ham
and then probably take take and this the
computer gives white a substantial
advantage but i'm not sure the rook and
two bishops is really a lot I mean and
if they coordinate this can be can be a
force the problem is I'm really am a bit
low on pawns if you check consider
something like that there's this
additional idea and it gets tricky if
I'm only have one porn again yeah I can
basically never be better in the
position now probably um yeah what is
this very difficult but would have been
very interesting to see this played out
but unluckily a lost connection very
hard to hard to judge I don't think all
white cannot be a 9 in big trouble
because of the pawn count I only we keep
one poem probably and the only question
is if I get enough activity two to hold
it he has got the g and h phone but
these are not so easily pushed as well
yeah very difficult and unfortunately we
don't see it played out bit unlucky
alright thanks for watching